[Music]  we're here at lowry's  prime rib our name is our specialty  we've been serving slow roasted prime  ribs of beef since 1938.  so when you come to lowry's you not only  get dinner but you also get a show  our surfers spin the salads table side  so everyone can watch their salads being  prepared as well as our carvers carve  prime rib  [Music]  tableside  [Music]  we're open seven days a week for dinner  we're open monday through thursday from  five to nine  friday and saturday from five to ten and  sundays from four to nine in addition to  dining in if you're not comfortable  coming up to dinner quite yet we are  offering curbside pickup we will bring  your order right to your car  and you can place an order on our  website at lowryslasvegas.com